even crazier even more bad kids we are
now to spot we're believable women we
need to movement is actually a
right-wing trap so the the left is in a
really bad spot the feminist movement in
a very bad spot because the feminists
told us during brick the brick Cavanagh
hearings that anytime any woman makes an
accusation no matter how outlandish no
matter how uncorroborated no matter how
much it changes we have to believe those
women we need to strip men of due
process rights and we need to destroy
their careers all right there was no
evidence that Breck 'van aw dude
anything untoward to that lady
Christine Ford no evidence that
Christine Ford ever met Brett Kavanaugh
she couldn't tell us when the alleged
incident took place who was there in the
room how many people were there where it
was the one friend she said was around
at the time said it didn't happen she
changed her stories you got caught in a
bunch of lies right she was completely
uncredible then there was another lady
who was somehow even less credible Julie
sweat Nick who said that Brett Kavanaugh
was a gang rapist an immediate Jake
Tapper oh they were promoting this woman
they were promoting all this trash and
they said if you didn't believe these
women then you were some some monster
now of course Joe Biden has much more
credible allegations against him and all
of a sudden they're saying now we
shouldn't believe that woman so Susan
Faludi who is a journalist writing the
New York Times
she says believe all women is a
right-wing trap Joe Biden has been
accused of sexual assaulting
conservatives are having a field day oh
we're having a field day no we're just
holding you to your own standards
exalting that they've caught feminists
in a new hypocrisy trap a woman with no
corroboration beyond contemporaneous
accounts charge is a powerful man with a
decades-old crime hmm doesn't that sound
mighty close to Christine Blasi for its
complaint against Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh no it doesn't actually
because the woman who's alleging the the
crime against Joe Biden has
contemporaneous corroboration and
Christine Ford didn't so actually it's
not this one seems a whole lot more
credible than Christine Ford even though
you're not believing this lady because
it's politically inconvenient for you
anyway hey doesn't that sound mighty
close - Christine Ford yes
this time many liberals who've
championed the me2 movement seem
skeptical gotcha but in fact believe all
women does have an asterisk it's never
been feminist boilerplate what we are
witnessing is another instance of the
right to crying what it imagines to be
the American women's movement spend some
mind-numbing hours tracking the origins
of believe all women on social media
sites and news databases as I did and
you'll discover how language like a
virus can mutate overnight all of a
sudden
yesterday's quotes suffer the insertion
of some foreign DNA that makes them easy
to weaponize in this case that intrusion
that foreign intrusion is a word all all
insertion was all the rage during the
Cavanagh hearing so they're saying
actually the phrase was believed women
not believe all women its conservatives
who added the all to it and that totally
changes the meaning except that isn't
true that's the that's the big problem
the women's March we eat it out we
believe all survivors Kirsten Gillibrand
tweeted out do we value women do we
believe women do we give them the
opportunity to tell their story to be
heard will we ensure that they get the
justice they deserve we must fight to be
a country that answers yes every time
every time Hillary Clinton this one the
most ironic every survivor of sexual
assault deserves to be heard believed
and supported everyone except for the
ones that Hillary Clinton spent decades
smearing I guess but everyone actually
the Hillary Clinton part is is important
to remember here the left has always
been hypocritical on feminism all the
way back all the way back to the 90s all
the way before that feminism has never
been a tool to help women and treat
women fairly and apply standards equally
no it's just a political instrument for
attacking Republicans and not attacking
Democrats going easy on Democrats we can
go back and type we can Google this we
can see that they're lying to us now
even the idea by the way that believe
all women is different than believe
women
what's the difference if there's no
difference at all if you say believe
women as a categorical statement that is
exactly the same as saying believe all
women
you could say believe some women I guess
that would be the alternative but
obviously none of the left ever said
that they believe women believe all
women it's exactly the same thing and
beyond that they actually they actually
said believe all women before
[Music]
[Music]